foreign
[Laughter]
what the hell happened this camera's out
of whack
it's not it's not the camera that's
moved I think it's just bright it's too
bright in here what's going on this one
this light back here keeps like
switching colors like without you
touching glue right now so I don't know
what the [__] going on it's like oh
God it's all kind of crazy [__] going on
behind here that I'm not even involved
in but uh but yeah so hey everybody hope
you've been having a good weekend so far
and we're finally [__] finally
getting around to uh getting around to
The Breakfast Club this is a steelbook
Edition sent by Louie look how Fantastic
look it's like a lot there it's like I
haven't seen it in a long time
haven't seen it in a long time and once
again
Louie's taste hold up
they hold up that's a great movie I I
haven't seen it in a long long [__]
time
I see it again and and I saw a lot more
in it the second time or you know what
as now that I'm older I see a lot more
in it than I used to yeah it's a great
movie
it's almost kind of like a play it's
taking place in detention
but all kinds of cool [__] [__]
happens it's it's about
the social class system of the American
High School System
uh back in the 80s but it held I think
it was still like that now Soph said her
High School wouldn't like that but
you know she's up in Michigan so I don't
know if they're still if High School is
still like this in in some places in
other places it is but but it was like
this in the 80s in other countries too
because the if you watch the extras yeah
there's some really great um extras on
here like they have interviews with
almost all of the principal cast and
yeah uh you know they got letters from
all around the world saying that oh yeah
it's just like that here in the
Netherlands or you know Central America
you know yeah I feel like John Hughes
movies I mean they're kind of synonymous
with the 1980s which just like we were
watching these I mean how old was I when
this came out this came out in 1985 yeah
and so I was 13. so I was slightly
younger than uh the characters but you
know I think I was still in junior high
school
yeah because you're a couple years older
than me
um but you could still relate to it even
if you were in junior high school you
know what I mean because you knew like
how it was gonna go but I don't know I
might not have seen it when I was 13
though I might have seen it like a year
or two later
I remember like when it first came out
thinking it was a chick flick
so I I didn't I saw it while I was in
high school but it had been out for a
couple years right so I was because of
oh man that movie's old it's like two
years old forever
isn't that funny yeah they used to think
now it's like two years I'd be talking
about something I'd be like hey this
happened the other day and then I was
like oh [__] that was like five years
ago yeah yeah it seemed like the other
day the faster it goes by
but uh I think I saw this
as a junior
and I liked it I remember liking it oh
yeah yeah it's cool but then I kind of
quickly forgot about it the other things
were happening
but uh seen it the other day what was
that two days ago yeah we watched it I
think Thursday night we watched it yeah
I was blown away by a lot of little
details about it the acting's real good
the writing's really good
um
things are kind of set up in the story
as it unfolds
kind of
I don't want to say it's symbolic yeah I
guess you could say no not really
symbolic just kind of
when you see it you you you can relate
to it
you can pretty much relate to all the
characters even though even the adults
you can relate to them yeah uh there
aren't any bad people really
in it like uh
it's just different points of view it's
good movie and everybody the great thing
about every character in this is that
even though like when you first meet
them like obviously some of them are
huge [__] like you know John Bender
he's played by Judd Nelson yeah but as
you get to know everybody you see where
they're all coming from and why they're
acting the way they're acting you know
we say you start to like sympathize with
each of them as they start to realize
that they're more alike than different
so you're kind of coming to the same
conclusion that they're coming to
Benders Benders the the [__]
but as you as you get to know him
there's a reason why he's like that
that's his defense mechanism and this
this movie wouldn't happen without that
character because he's the agent of
chaos he's the one that's constantly
moving the story forward hey let's get
out of here hit a smoke pot hey let's go
to the other side of the let's go walk
to the other side of the school yeah
let's keep the door open okay let's [__]
with this dude hey this [__] with Claire
you know it's just right without him the
story wouldn't unfold they'd just sit
there in detention really not talking to
each other
so he's the main character if you ask me
yeah he's the Catalyst they needed
somebody to do a catalyst because like
you said if he wasn't there yeah to kind
of spur the other characters into doing
stuff then they would probably just sit
there like they were supposed to yeah
for me the movie is mostly just about
him and Claire
those are the main characters
I played by Molly rinkwald I bring all
this place Gloria yeah even though you
know what's interesting so this was only
John Hughes I think this is only his
second movie he actually
um was this only a second movie a 16
Candles came out before this one and
Molly Ringwald and Anthony Michael Hall
were in that one too
so when he was working on this movie he
was like well I want you you guys to be
in The Breakfast Club also
but Molly Ringwald
um he initially wanted her to play Ali
sheedy's character the weird The Goth
weirdo
um and she really really wanted to play
the [__] princess character and John
Hughes was like I don't know I you know
I don't I don't really know if that's
because who they wanted for uh the her
character initially
um Laura Dern I think she was in
consideration uh Jody Foster
um Robin Wright I think there were like
some others so they wanted somebody like
much more princessy or blonde or
something like that
um but Molly Ringwald campaign's really
really hard to be the princess character
because like I said initially he was you
know wanted her to be kind of like the
more Awkward character but she didn't
really want to do that so that's what
Ali Sheedy ended up with and the thing
about it though is that Judd Nelson's
character
um
so he's great in this I mean and he's
he's funny as [__] like he's because
he's on a lot of the extras on here and
he's like talking about the experience
making the movie and he's hilarious
so
um initially it was between they
actually were thinking about Nicholas
Cage for that role
um and Nicolas Cage you know is quite
young at this point he'd only done
valley girl like a couple years privates
previously which we still have to do
valley girl one of these days but
um in the end it was down to Judd Nelson
and John Cusack and actually John Cusack
got cast first but I guess when they
were still doing rehearsals and stuff
like that um John Hughes decided that
John Cusack wasn't quote unquote
intimidating enough so Judd Nelson got
it how Judd Nelson got it was that he
wore exactly the same clothes that you
see Bender wearing in the [__] in the
movie and he just came in and just
started acting like that like he just
did he did method acting yeah and that
it kind of caused some problems on the
set I heard because he acted like that
all the time
constantly [__] with Molly Ringwald
and she really did not like it um and he
was like constantly [__] with Anthony
Michael Hall and and John Hughes was
actually going to fire him at some point
um but the other actors were like no no
he's just doing the method thing even
though it's irritating his [__] that
he's just like acting like a obnoxious
[__] like 24 7. but it ended up
really because they what they did was
they put them all together and they
rehearsed for three weeks
and then they shot the movie in order
which they don't usually do they shot it
in sequence and they actually let a lot
of the actors
um they let them improvise so some of
the stuff you know that great line where
um Emilio estevez's character Andy like
he asks uh Brian you know the nerd or
whatever like why do you even have a
fake ID and he goes so I can vote that
was an improv really yeah I mean like
Anthony Michael Hall came up with that
yeah
I remember thinking that was like one of
my favorite lines that shit's [__]
hilarious yeah
and Anthony Michael Hall at the time was
sucking kind of Crest Fallen that uh he
wasn't getting any action from his girls
they would kept they were calling him
[__] milk and cookies because he was
sweet Allie she called
he's still kind of mad about it he's not
mad about it but it's like little did
they know that he'd [__] grow up to
be a [__] hunk out yeah
which that still blows my [__] mind
because whenever you see it's very
different I mean it's funny because
um we noticed this when we were watching
the movie too is that he's actually when
he goes in there to like break up the
fight between Andy and Bender and he's
clearly like taller than both of them
they said what happened Judd Nelson said
that oh Anthony Michael Hall like went
through a growth spurt like while they
were shooting the movie he wasn't taller
than them I guess when they started but
then like as it went off yeah because I
think he was doing
um was it the first vacation or european
vacation I can't remember because I
think he got taller during that one he's
at least six foot yeah but yeah so that
that's what's so funny is he goes in
there to break up the fight between
these two tough guys and Tom was like
he's taller than both of them
[Laughter]
tall being you know being Pole but uh
later on he did a couple other roles as
uh looking what what was that one movie
he actually played a bully in it yeah
well the first time that I actually saw
him because I didn't see him for the
same years yeah and then he was in
Edward Scissorhands Edward Scissorhands
he was in Edward Scissorhand he plays
basically a bully on him yeah he's like
a big like bulky athlete and I was like
holy [__] [__] that's the same dude
same dude that was in Weird Science and
16 Candles like he still looks nerdy and
weedy in this movie but not as nerdy and
weedy as he looked in Weird Science and
16 Candles I mean 16 candles they put
the braces on him and all that he blows
it out of the water in the dead zone
series that he captains is [__] John
yeah I mean if you haven't seen The Dead
Zone series with Anthony Michael Hall
please watch it because I feel like a
lot of people don't talk about it and
it's really really you can buy the whole
series for next yeah it's really really
good I feel like nobody talks about it
anymore
um holy Parish of Doom said I thought
Emilio Estevez was initially cast to be
the stoner I think um yeah he was but
the thing about it was that they
couldn't find because Bender that was
the last one that was cast and I think
they initially wanted like Emilio
Estevez to play more that role because
up to then hadn't he been in he kind of
played a tough like in characters but
like he was in wasn't he in The
Outsiders and I kind of feel like he'd
been in a couple other movies before
that where he played like a bully or
like a tough guy so they were kind of
gonna get it but I think he just ended
up with like the athlete role because
they couldn't really find anybody that
could play it and so he just ended up
playing it so it's always really funny
that like whoever ended up like I can't
imagine look I love John Cusack okay
he's like one of my favorite actors
legit but I don't know
I don't know if I can see him as Bender
I can't see anybody but Judd Nelson as
Bender like in that role he Nails it I
mean he's like he's a little bit over
the top but that totally goes with that
character yeah and like you said if he
wasn't in the movie like nothing would
really happen because this is
essentially do you know this movie only
costs a million dollars to make that's
it it's like nothing that's like nothing
well and the only reason was because
this was supposed to be John Hughes that
he wanted this to be like his first
movie that he would direct you know I
mean because he wrote and produced and
stuff but um you know the execs were
like well you know you don't really have
the experience we want to get another
director so he was able to convince them
by saying hey we're just gonna have this
tiny cast we're gonna shoot it in one
location and it's just gonna cost a
million dollars so it's essentially like
a stage play and it's he didn't write it
as a stage play but interestingly and I
didn't know this until I started looking
into some [__] later on and actually
John cappellos the guy that plays Carl
the janitor he said this on some of the
extras too he's said um but I think it
was John Hughes that he actually adapted
it into a play later on because like
High School uh theater draw like drama
coaches and stuff like that were asking
for because they wanted their uh their
classes to like put it on yeah so this
would actually be really good because
it's you know it's not you know yeah
there's action I guess like when they
escape from the room and like run around
and stuff but it's mostly just like
talking yeah and I think that's and it's
funny I had forgotten because I've seen
this movie a billion times I've like so
many times that I've had it memorized
but I haven't seen it for probably 10
years at least
but I mean one I remembered every single
line of dialogue like I had forgotten
nothing but I had forgotten though how
contained this movie is it essentially
takes place entirely in one room yeah
there's just like some outside and the
funny thing is a little bit on the
hallway they go right right they're out
in front of the school yeah
but you don't see anything you don't see
that much it's mostly just in the
library right and then they throw Bender
in the damn storage closet you can
remember the storage room they kind of
put him in a cell
a lot of cool [__] happens in the movie
but like I said it's like a play and
it's all Talking Heads basically they're
just talking to each other things are
happening and it's unfolding but it
actually at the end there's like there's
like it's got great scenes of like
Triumph and romance and [__] you know
like what goes down between Claire and
and and Bender
I mean
eventually she says [__] it she's a
virgin all right and um it's implied
that Bender has girlfriends but they're
all hoes basically that they don't yeah
they don't say that out right that's
kind of yeah like he's like you don't
blame one guy one girl and he's like
what do you or that kind of [__] you
know or I can't remember exactly and
then he says too um he's like he asked
her too it's like why do you have so
much [__] in your person like that she's
like I don't know I guess I don't throw
anything away and he's like yeah neither
do I I like talking about his girlfriend
yeah yeah like he just keeps them all
around so he can bang them like yeah
whatever I don't think they're loyal to
him though either well no that's what I
mean they're just kind of like because
uh and then so anyway he's like that and
then Claire was a virgin even though she
didn't want to admit it although Ali
Sheedy that I love that scene where Ali
shitty gets her to admit it by saying
that yeah she was a nymphomaniac and she
told her shrink and it's like what do
you do when you told her he nailed me
yeah and then like she goes on this big
long thing and then she's like I'm not a
nymphomaniac okay I
don't know if you guys have seen this in
a while you know you really should we
see it again it's uh
watching it as adults is even better
um
but I don't want to steal the movie's
Thunder but you know when Claire goes in
there and basically [__] kisses
bender and [__] he's like why'd you do
that because and she said because you
wouldn't and then and then it ends like
in a kind of like a moment of Triumph
where for at least for Bender
Bender's out there saying goodbye to her
in front of her dad's car in a full view
of her [__] Rich Dad she pulls one of
the diamond earrings out that he gave
her and he she gives it to bender and
lays a big old smooch on him yeah and
then and then leaves and then he puts
the [__] earring in his ear and [__]
because he had his ears like oh my gosh
that's it man
talked his way into it you know although
I always kind of thought I don't know
maybe maybe this is the cynic in me
talking but I always thought maybe that
the implication was that when Monday
came they were all just gonna pretend
they didn't know each other again well
this song Don't You Forget About Me is
second playing at that during that's
true so I don't think so maybe not I
think maybe they've changed the Paradigm
I think I think what happened was is I
think
um they were going to say [__] it and
they were friends
no matter what anybody said
yeah I think that's what it is because I
think that's another came The Breakfast
Club right that's another great scene
too is when um when they're having that
discussion where you know they're like
what happens on Monday like you know are
we gonna still be friends or are we just
gonna pretend we you know we don't know
each other and [__] like that and the
first Claire was like nah this is it
well and Brian says well I wouldn't do
that to you guys like you know we'd
still be friends but then Claire says
well well um your friends wouldn't mind
because they look up to us yeah and I
was like well the thing about that line
is that she's probably right but it's
really really [__] to like say that out
loud like I said there are no bad
characters in this Claire no they're all
great she was a good girl yeah she was
just very much into group think and and
very much tried to get approval from her
friends that was her weakness really so
she couldn't break outside her little
click but better I think got her to to
do that she was the one that approached
him you never got her out of that yeah
and she gave
the reason why I think that they became
a couple and that they all became
friends is because
Claire gave her earring that her dad
gave her
that real diamond earrings to Bender in
front of the dad yeah so you know that
she couldn't back off of that
yeah he's gonna be like who's that yeah
so she basically had now declared war
on yeah on her dad basically yeah you
can't go back she didn't like her Dad or
Mom anyway they were always fighting so
she's breaking away from that so she's
becoming independent and she's not gonna
let her friends tell her who she can and
cannot hang out with that's how I
interpreted it yeah
um and and what was sporto's name Andy
Andy and Andy kind of went through the
same thing yeah he's like [__] it I like
this girl yeah talking about the Ali
Sheedy girl what was her it was the name
of that character Allison Allison that's
right I thought it was Alison but I was
gonna know her name is Ali Sheedy yeah
but um yeah but the characters the
character's name is Allison too and then
some a lot of people thought that the
Allison character has sold out by
pulling her hair back after that kind of
different thing I believe Judd Nelson
spoke about spoke about that
in the in the uh
and the extra in the extras he didn't
believe so and I agreed with him
it was what happened was
is Allison and Claire had bonded
Claire was doing something nice for Al
Allison and doing her makeup and doing
her hair
and Allison is like why are you being so
nice to me and then
Claire goes because you you're let
you're letting me yeah
and
after it was done
it was her hair was pulled out of her
face she would have looked good even
with the old makeup on put her hair out
of her you couldn't really see who she
was right so then um Andy SAR Sporto
and he's like oh man she's hot yeah you
know after he'd already gotten to know
her you know by talking to her you know
but he didn't realize that she was that
good looking I think because she was
hiding behind a big mop hair yeah and
and real baggy
Proto goth clothing
Ally Sheedy says that she invented that
character's look and everything
based upon she said there was no goth
back then yeah she's right yes she said
that exact thing she said that she said
there wasn't really a goth thing but
there was the proto-goth girls that you
would see that looked like that they
were hanging out in the [__] cough in
the coffee shops yeah and they had all
black clothes on and they were always
like really cool and they were listening
to buy house and sisters so that's how
she modeled it after Joy Division I kind
of feel like she was a little bit like
that yeah and she even said that like in
some of the extras she said I didn't
really even have to like invent the
character because a lot of it was just
her yeah
um they were a little bit older I kind
of feel like now Molly Ringwald I can't
[__] believe this she was as young
she was as she was the same age as her
character she was 16. 16. she looks like
she's in her 20s but she's moving now
the other ones I think Anthony Michael
Hall was slightly younger too but the
other ones were in their early 20s like
Judd Nelson I think was 24 and like the
other ones were 22 23 something like
that was shitty said that um
was always 40.
yeah she was always 30. she said she was
30 at 16. so she said we were working on
this movie because like I said you know
Molly Ringwald she still had to go to
school because she was only a teenager
so and she's like it was so weird to us
she's like why did she have to go to
school oh yeah she's only 16 because she
always seemed so much older yeah not she
didn't look older but she acted older
and like she was always she said she was
always very sophisticated and she always
came off as much more mature than her
the whole Sushi thing and all the uh
her elevated tastes and interests
evidently that's the way she was and
that wasn't typical for California
teenagers at a time well she actually I
don't know if you know this but after
all of the teen movies that she was in
and she kind of wanted to get out of
that like you know and be more a serious
actress she actually moved to France and
lived there for ages and she was in like
a ton of French movies okay so she
speaks fluent French and all that kind
of stuff but yeah because that's I feel
like she felt like she got Typecast in
the United States
um you know as a team as being in teen
movies because she was in so many of
them she had to get the [__] up so she
yeah so she went to France and she had
like a really long career and like I was
not was not a really a great scene
anyway I mean [__] I have to say
though that Molly Ringwald
um later on she was not on the extras on
the the extras that we watched on this
and I thought because I thought I heard
something about her like saying she was
mad at John Hughes or something like
that but I don't think it was as bad as
that
um because she did turn up at the
tribute for him like after he died
because I think he died in what the 2010
or something like that and she was like
when they were honoring him at the
Oscars or whatever she did like turn up
for that like as most of the other cast
members did but she did come out and say
later on that she didn't love in this
movie that um that Claire ended up with
Bender after he had done the thing under
the desk yeah like the which is
essentially like sexual assault I mean
it's kind of you know it's kind of
implied like what happened but she was
kind of arguing with John Hughes even
back then was arguing to take that out
uh but he didn't want to yeah uh so she
was like we got out of jail and looked
at it and sorry he was hiding from the
teacher and he sees her panties and puts
his hand in there and she goes and she
like crunches her crunches her head yeah
her yeah so yeah so even after some Tom
Foolery that would have happened though
man that's true but I'm just saying that
she that she didn't love the idea that
they had that scene in there then she
ends up with Bender at the end but um so
she argued with him like about it like
to get it taken out but you know they
didn't take it out and the thing about
it is there was a lot of let's not let's
not lie there was a lot of problematic
stuff like in 80s movies
um I'm speaking specifically not so much
of the John Hughes one I mean there are
some in John he's movies like The Long
duck dog thing and all that but um one
of the things I was thinking of was the
whole Revenge of the Nerds thing where
he dresses up as the girl's boyfriend
and then like has sex with her and I'm
just like that's that's kind of that's
pretty problematic yeah but you could
get away with [__] like that in the
movies right I'm just I'm just saying
that what I was gonna say was that so
there was a lot of like way worse [__]
in 80s movies um by comparison The
Breakfast Club is pretty
uh you know there's there's nothing that
bad in there there was a lot of teen
movies where part of the [__] in part
of the movies the the guys are trying to
[__]
do peep and Tom [__] on the girls and
[__] while they're [__] well that was
the whole premise of porkies yeah yeah
[Laughter]
take their clothes off and [__] yeah
but that kind of stuff was happening it
was yeah it was just it was a more
coming out of the 70s and the 60s you
know a lot of sexual Liberation and [__]
and they're just there were the rules
were different back then and I don't
think people took [__] very seriously in
fact everything was just funny games
that was the thinking no some people
would get pissed but I don't think they
cared maybe smack chicks on the ass all
the time
if you liked her if she guess you were
friends with her
I mean that [__] was going on in Europe
and Brazil was like that
they were groping groping people hey
baby you know just they're just the way
they were man somebody gross man I'm
breaking their [__] wrist
um they just played it off Brett air
said wasn't there a scene in 16 candles
that had something to do with Molly's
panties yeah because there was a whole
thing where her and and the geek Anthony
Michael Hall's character in 16 Candles
um he had bet his friends that he would
have sex with her and would get her
panties as proof and obviously she
doesn't have sex with them but he feels
she feels bad for him so she says okay
well I'll give you my underwear you know
what I mean so and then like later on
she's like I can't believe I gave my
panties to a geek yeah
but she didn't actually have sex with
him for her she just gave him the
underwear which is you know that's
pretty weird too but um but yeah so and
I think Ali Sheedy too was like she
didn't really like that that they had
changed her character so much like the
whole like glamor makeover thing she
well she wanted to do she said I didn't
have a problem with like being having
the hair pulled back or anything like
that but she was like I thought the pink
she stopped like that was a little much
I think it was too I think it was a
little much she's like I I argued for
just like a white wife beater or
something you know like an undershirt
yeah which you know but she's like the
pink with the little lace on it she's
like you know I kind of feel like that
character wouldn't have been wearing
that underneath no I mean when the [__]
because I dressed like that in high
school and I wouldn't wear anything like
she'd have been wearing something like a
like a cut up Joy Division t-shirt yeah
T-shirt with its sleeves cut off of it
like the v-neck cut into it yeah like I
said I think it would have been better
if it was like still even white would
have been okay but like still like like
maybe like a gray or a black just like
an undershirt you know I mean just plain
I think the fact that they went too far
in that direction she didn't really love
it either and I could have done without
that big poofy thing in her hair yeah
like whatever the [__] that was but you
know what I mean and I also could have
done without Molly ring ball being like
well you know you look better with
without all that black [__] around your
eyes and the weird thing is that she
didn't really have that much nah eye
makeup but like she doesn't she didn't
have as much eye makeup on as I have on
right now I just said back then that's
true like that was accurate and she's
like I like all that black [__] I'm like
yeah leave her alone I like that black
[__] too
now some some Yuppie chick [__]
preppy chick would have
they're gonna get all that black [__]
around here that's exactly what they
would have done and then that's true and
exactly would have tried to put that
hairdo on her yeah yeah they were just
[__] around though they were in
detention
yeah they're becoming friends yeah like
I get it it doesn't make me mad or
anything like that but it was something
I remember it being like a point of
discussion uh you know back in the 80s
when we first watched the movie we're
like ah why they have to do that to her
it's like you know what I mean why
couldn't she have just like stayed they
could have just pulled her hair back and
like not really done anything that
drastic well kind of the same thing in
[__] um uh the movie where they take
the goth girl and [__] the Tim Burton
movie where they [__] guys girl
[__] then they'd straighten her out
Beetlejuice Beetlejuice yeah although
she still had like a black
um like a like a what what do they call
that thing like an underskirt type thing
yeah so she did kind of yeah like a
petticoat there you go that was the word
I was looking for but um yeah they did
kind of like straighten around at the
end even though she looked way cooler in
the beginning yeah with like the bit
with all the big hair and the veils and
[__] like that oh my God that was like
one of my aspirational I'm like holy
[__] look at her [__] outfits yeah
but it wasn't acceptable and those big
[__] hats and stuff I'm like oh my
God that's not mainstream exceptions
that's fantastic they're like she had
like that big [__] hair she looked so
[__] there was a messages like that
it
in the 80s
not so much in the 90s but in the 80s
there were there was these subtle
messages to conform to oh big time and I
think that and I you know and it's kind
of like a form too it's just no not
really yeah they're kind of boring they
would conform to the damn shopping mall
really what they're talking about and I
think that's right for The Gap I think
that's the problem I had with the Ali
Sheedy Makeover at the end is that it's
kind of sending and I'm sure that wasn't
what he intended maybe but it did kind
of send the subtle message oh well you
have to look a certain way like you have
to be prettier you have to look like
everybody else like otherwise dudes
won't like you or nobody will like you
you know what I mean yeah I liked all
the characters they even like I even
like Sporto
uh he he was he was likable
um he uh [__]
he was just under a lot of pressure his
dad was making him do stuff he didn't
really want to do so he could get a
scholarship there's a lot of hidden
stuff where you know like
um uh [__] The Judd Nelson character
what was his name again
Bender
asked the custody he says my friend here
would like to uh he he may be pursuing a
career in the custodial Arts you know
and there's something to be said about
that because if he doesn't get his
scholarship that's what he's going to be
he's gonna be a [__] janitor because
that's what that's what happens to a
ball player when he can't
he's going to be a [__] janitor all
right if he doesn't get his scholarship
so um and then the janitor goes well I'm
a surf I'm a peon yeah
I love John Capella's in this he's kind
of secretly running the situation he
knows everybody's what everybody's doing
knows about all the weed and Bender's
Locker he knows it
knows what the girls are [__] saying
and writing
uh even gets uh that teacher under his
thumb I guess right yeah Paul Gleason
yeah yeah it gets yeah he gets 50 bucks
off of Hanford because he he catches him
going through the confidential files
yeah on the other teachers and like look
at all three yeah and that guy Paul
Gleason is great in this too I mean he's
such a [__]
douchebag what the [__] jerk this
dude is yeah like you can kind of
understand and I really like the scene
where him and Carl the janitor are like
talking and you know uh he's just
sitting there going it's like oh these
kids they get more more arrogant every
year blah blah and Carl actually kind of
like just brings him down he's like no
man it's like the kids haven't changed
you have yeah you know what I mean
um yeah and older and this shit's not as
fun as it was and you know yeah
attacking your [__] real seriously you
thought you thought being a teacher was
going to be just fun and games but no
it's [__] work man this is your life
now you know just yeah you got him right
yeah is he totally pegged him yeah now
he's stuck in this career he's not
really happy with you know and um
and I guess the janitor kind of had a
sense of freedom because he doesn't have
to live up to anything
yeah he's just he was very Sage Yeah
Carl the Janet yeah he's a great [__]
character somehow he knows
um the Anthony Michael Hall's character
what's that what's the name of that
character Brian Brian he knows Brian and
Brian knows him but they never really
clear they never really clear up how
they know each other yeah it's just kind
of like implied that they're friends
yeah because at first Brian is like
embarrassed about it yeah does your dad
work here yeah Judd Nelson says and he's
just like shut up you know what I mean
but then like at the end if you notice
um when they're leaving the school like
he just goes hey Carl bye you know what
I mean so he's like not ashamed of his
relationship with the lowly janitor
anymore you know what I mean so it's
just kind of shows like oh that's a good
job actually those guys get paid pretty
well I think but probably uh they
probably get 30 grand though I well a
high school that's not great money
nowadays but yeah well you know there's
enough to live on
[Music]
it's better than Pride working retail
um I would much rather be a janitor than
work retail I'm gonna say that right now
even though you have to like clean up
kids throw up and everything like that
which I'm not a big fan of but um you
know but like I said pretty much
anything is better than working retail
yeah holy [__] that's like the mouth of
hell I [__] hate that I hate having
to deal with people any job where I can
just be by myself and just get on with
[__] is like way way better but I was
gonna say too when you were talking
about
Emilio esteve has his character uh
that's another [__] great team like I
said that whole like um kind of linchpin
scene where they're all sitting around
talking about
um you know their their backgrounds and
like what they did to get in here and
[__] like that that's just like such a
great scene and I love Emilio Estevez in
that part where he's talking about what
he did to get you know put in detention
and he says you know I taped Larry
Lester's buns together and everybody
thinks that's funny at first but then
like as he tells the story like he just
started picking on this kid because his
dad is always saying like oh you know
he's always like picking a weakness and
he's just like oh so I thought he was
just trying to like impress his dad and
he was saying like all his friends were
like cheering him on and stuff and then
he said afterward he felt so [__] bad
about it because all he could think
about was this kid having to go home and
tell his dad like what had happened to
him and it was like so humiliating yeah
and so the fact that he had like that
Insight was just that was the time
because I kind of feel like the first
few times I saw this movie I really
really did not because I'm not a big fan
of like you know when I was in school
and I wasn't a big fan of like the jock
people and [__] like that they always
seem like d-bags to me and I was like no
they're not all of them aren't like that
but a lot of them were and so when I
first saw this movie I was just kind of
like oh this [__] [__] right here
like I didn't really like him but like
after that scene I was kind of like oh
okay so he's not and that's kind of
what's cool about the movie is that even
if you don't like the people at the
beginning like you get some insight into
their character yeah it was about the
pecking order the Dynamics his dad was
kind of picking on him so he was picking
on another guy the guy that was weaker
that was weaker than him it was kind of
like the uh and that happens a lot like
with bullies yeah it's usually usually
his dad's beating the [__] out of the
bullet yeah and well that was what and
they say that that happens with Bender
as well like the reason that he's such a
dick and he's just so antagonistic is
because I mean his dad's like beating
the [__] out of him yeah and they I love
too like the whole opening sequence
to see this is like this is good writing
right here the whole opening sequence
where the students are arriving at
detention there's like not much dialogue
like not much is said or anything like
that but you can you realize so much
about the characters just from the way
that they arrive you know what I mean
Bender is not dropped off by anybody he
just dropped he just walks there by
himself so he's kind of like alone you
know what I mean
um you know Allison's character she gets
out the car and like she kind of tries
to say bye to her mom or dad or
whoever's in the car and they just drive
off like without saying anything to her
and she was also riding in the back seat
did you notice that yeah like not in the
front yeah and so you know and some of
the other ones like they have
conversations and stuff but Brian's
character you know what's interesting
somebody pointed out earlier that um
that John Hughes actually plays his dad
when he's picking him up like at the end
of the day but did you know that when he
gets dropped off in the morning like his
mom and his sister who are in the car is
this the first or the last time this is
gonna happen that's his
[Laughter]
I just found that out today and I was
like I hope they're not really like that
because man that Mom was a [__] there
there were some possible hidden messages
to uh in the movie to [__] kinda
kind of a as a reveal to bit and to
bender and his uh his destiny
um
the teacher what was the teacher's name
Mr Vernon Mr Mr Vernon says oh you think
that [__] Bender do you think he's
funny come back in five years and you'll
see how he is he'll be real [__]
funny you know basically they're saying
that this dude's a [__] criminal and
he's not going to mount anything
later on Bender's running through the
[__] school [__] smacking doors
trying to get as much attention as he
possibly can away from his friends so
they can get back to safety and he's
calling in all the attention in on
himself he's singing I want to be an
Airborne Ranger yeah as a very Ranger
[__] thing to do he's drawing fire so
your friends can [__] make it
and uh
a lot of times guys like Bender that's
who ends up being a [__] rager or
joining Airborne units they're either go
to jail or that yeah yeah but the
military actually is where they want to
be at least back in our days
because uh he'll be in there with other
guys like him and they straighten up
give him discipline and Order and
self-esteem and they come out four to
eight years later you would recognize
them you know totally different guys
better A lot better
unless unless something bad happens to
him you know bad [__] can happen in Duty
they come back
[__] psychos you know but I don't
know I had a feeling that the the subtle
message was is how the hell would Bender
know that song because he's saying he's
saying that Cadence correct correctly
yeah he must have
had fantasized about being an Airborne
rager
yeah that's the thing now you're kind of
wondering like did he maybe want to join
the military after yeah because the
thing about Bender get away from his dad
right yeah the thing about Bender is
that I mean he's not
he's a [__] for sure but he's not a
terrible person like deep down he's a
good guy like deep down he's a good guy
I knew guys like this yeah and I knew
guys like this too in high school and
they straightened up it's like you know
and he didn't do anything I mean other
than the like biting Molly Ringwald of
the [__] but um he didn't bite her no
I'm just saying yeah I was just saying
because of that he just tried to put his
head in here he was teasing her but I
mean all he did to go to detention was
he pulled a fire alarm which you know
kids used to do that all the time but
that's not great but I'm just saying it
wasn't because he didn't kill anybody
um you know what I mean and he didn't do
anything that bad so mostly he was just
a smart ass yeah and to be honest
um Mr Vernon was such a dick that
you can't really blame the kid you know
what I mean
because look at how Mr Vernon that scene
too like where he puts um where he puts
Bender in the storage closet like locks
him in there yeah like after he like
escaped from the room or whatever and he
puts him in there and then Mr Vernon
essentially like threatens to kick his
ass
and then he says to him he's just like
you know what who's gonna believe you
you know what I mean yeah and the fact
that he's trying to get Bender to hit
him like he's trying to bait him into
hitting him
and I think Bender didn't like the look
on his face I was always kind of intro I
was like is Bender actually afraid of
him because he's thinking it's like his
dad or is he realizing this [__]
is trying to bait me into hitting him
and then no one's going to believe me
because I'm just some delinquent yeah he
knew and he's you know what I mean so
he's like yeah I'm not taking that bait
yeah you know because he wasn't dumb
yeah no he's smart right
so I always kind of thought because I
mean the look on his face he kind of
looked scared but I think I think the
look was maybe not scared as like
disbelieving that like this guy actually
went that far like when no one else was
around well I think he really basically
said I think he I think he realized that
he had pushed that dude that far and
that's yeah yeah that adults have limits
I don't think he knew that adults had
limits I think he thought that these
school people had an unlimited patience
for what he was because look at it he
was pushing and pushing and pushing and
I think he got scared he realized he
drew this dude [__] crazy yeah and
then he might be dangerous that you
punch that dude [__] you'll be thrown
out of school forever and then maybe you
can't be an Airborne Ranger if you don't
have the damn high school diploma yeah
and then or maybe you go to jail
yeah and then there here you go
I had a feeling after hearing him
[__] sing in the Airborne cages is
that he actually wanted to leave home go
to military
yeah because his whole life was uh yeah
that was not great he's not gonna go to
college so how's he going to get out of
there
he wasn't I don't think he was I think I
think uh uh verden was wrong isn't it
Vernon that was his name Mr Vernon yeah
I think Mr Vernon was wrong I don't
think he'd just be the guy would just
sit around
you know letting his dad [__] with it he
had too much energy he had too much
energy he wanted too much Adventure he
wanted to live a life of danger just
like in the song yeah so he's gonna
[__] leave
you know the equivalent of [__]
joining the French Foreign Legion yeah
but who knows now he's with
hooked up with look that long-term name
Gonna Last in him uh no no
graduation day comes and he's better go
you know yeah because she's going off to
University he can't follow
yeah or she's going off to France or
yeah going to France University
we were laughing we're laughing so hard
at like and I remembered this scene too
because this doesn't really play the
same as it did in the 80s but when
everybody's doing their lunch you know
and she comes and starts taking the
sushi out of the bag and like you know
pouring the sauce and everything like
that and Bender is like
the [__] is that you know what I mean
where it's like nowadays everybody would
know what that was like it wouldn't be
that weird like it and it was weird it
would still be weird to like bring it to
lunch because it would be kind of she
had a little wooden table for it yeah
which is a little pretentious yeah even
if you do bring Sushi I kind of feel
like yeah can't you just bring like the
plastic one from Publix or something
like that I went to International High
School in Brazil we had a bunch of
Japanese female students there
and that's what they ate and and sushi
would sit around all day and then they'd
eat it but the raw fish
but it brought it in tupperware it
didn't come with a little [__]
yeah like that was just so [__]
precious and the fact that she [__]
did that yeah well you won't accept a
guy's tongue in your mouth and you're
gonna eat that
well like I said nobody would think that
was weird nowadays because it's like I
don't even know what the equivalent
would be nowadays because everybody like
I said everybody's Foodies now so it's
not like anybody is that mystified by
uh by anything in particular but in the
80s like sushi was seen as like ooh that
was very Chichi you know what I mean
like only rich people ate sushi I kind
of felt like in the mid 80s when this
came out yeah and then like the scene
like there were only a couple sushi
restaurants I'd be at in L.A right which
is [__] which is hilarious because like
I said now everybody [__] eats it but
yeah back then it was just very very
weird it was considered like very very
upper class you know what I mean yeah
um and then like a couple minutes later
when Andy like the wrestler like takes
out his lunch this is massive like
grocery bag yeah and it's like
sandwiches and a whole bag of chips and
a whole bag of donuts and like I'm
getting for a pepper like a banana
banana the big bad it was a big he had a
big bag of potato chips
a bag of donuts or was it I think it was
Donuts you see the donuts like it looked
like little like mini Donuts is what it
looked like three sandwiches wrapped up
yeah I think it's three three or four
yeah and he's just taking it out yeah he
had a quart of milk and a quarter yeah
yeah
and then uh a [__] an apple and a
banana
Clara better just like stare at him and
disbelief like and he's just like what
that's so funny I'm like how could
anybody [__] eat all that man and the
whole scene too with uh with [__] Ali
Sheedy with her lunch with her [__]
sandwich that had was that olive loaf it
was olive loaf I think it looked like um
then she threw it Captain Crunch and
pixie sticks and she really ate that in
like in real life like on the set yeah
because that's again some method acting
because I said we were watching it and I
remembered that scene and I was kind of
like that might be kind of good no maybe
if the bread was toasted I don't think
it would be that good if the bread
wasn't toasted it could be like right
I've been sitting with [__] Piccolo
for olive loaf maybe that's what gives
it that extra no
you don't know so is there anything else
you want to talk about anything else you
want to talk about breakfast club we're
Meandering no we're not we're still
talking about the Kobe we're we're
actually amazingly on topic for once are
we on what's the time uh uh 50 one
minutes where does this film take place
in Illinois
um yeah it's in Illinois I think it's
supposed to be like a suburb of Chicago
and I think they actually did shoot it
in not I think the town it's in Shermer
Illinois because that's the same place
that they set Weird Science this was
actually the same High School the
Interiors where they shot Ferris
Bueller's Day Off and they filmed both
of them at around the same time like
they had the same crew and everything
like that because I think Ferris
Bueller's Day Off was the one that came
out right after this but
um Jeffy art said interesting how our
palettes change over a generation what
was once considered exotic is now
commonplace yeah so it's that's what was
funny to me that is maybe one of the
only things see I'm really interested to
know
people that are teenagers now that are
the same age as the characters in this
movie
um watching this movie what strikes them
about it that's different now than you
know what I mean because it might be
stuff that I didn't think of no social
media no cell phones well right yeah I
mean that's pretty that's obvious but I
mean it does seem like a lot of younger
people are like really into 80s stuff
yeah so they still must relate to it on
some level there was somebody who
actually coined the term I forgot what
it was
but um
young people of today are experiencing
Nostalgia for the for
the 80s era that they never experienced
they never experienced what they have
Nostalgia for it yeah weird I guess it's
because it's
pre
-social media
everything's very normal
everything's physical
you know what I mean you're not getting
information from outside sources you're
only getting information from the people
that are around you right so it's like a
very low-tech way of living I guess from
their point of view but but
it's I guess it's less restrictive
because they're living online and social
media everything they do or say it can
be judged by all their friends
so there's no sense of privacy Maybe
yeah it's a lot harder to like hide yeah
we were hiding like crazy it's [__]
hot a teacher as teens hiding and doing
things in secret and
this group of friends and then that
group of friends and they didn't know
each other you move from one group to
the other they wouldn't know or they did
know yeah you really care but isn't that
funny that's funny to think about
nowadays but yeah there'd be no way I
mean nowadays like I said you post
pictures all over social media and
people be like who's that [__]
you know what I mean why are you hanging
on him yeah it's like oh man that dude
is like such a [__] yeah yeah but
because everybody's like super connected
like I said I don't know I think we came
from us because there's less
penalty that's social penalties because
there's less judgment because people
less interconnectivity people didn't
know so I guess we were kind of like
high risk High reward
low penalty the way we lived I guess
because I've heard that now they kind of
feel pretty restrictive they're like
they're being watched by all by their
friends list I guess
yeah I don't know because we're a
different generation we don't give a
[__] I don't give a [__] by that friend
of this
well that's what I mean and like I said
you know we're older so it's easy for us
to say like you know when you're young
yeah I mean when we were younger too
like you were and they go into it a lot
in this movie there's like there was a
lot of peer pressure and [__] like that
it just wasn't coming from the whole
entire world right you know what I mean
um like with social media it was just
coming from the immediate surroundings
which was bad enough uh so I'm sure it's
like a lot worse nowadays that you have
the whole [__] world looking at you
essentially like anytime they want to or
they make you think that the whole
world's looking at you I mean I imagine
to a teenager it would feel like that
yeah because you kind of feel like that
as you I mean I kind of felt like that
as a teenager anyway like in the 80s
even though we didn't even have social
media yeah but you kind of felt like
everyone was looking at you or like you
know thinking about you am I doing
something wrong it's like what am I am I
wearing the right thing am I doing the
right thing am I doing this and that so
it's like I kind of feel like teenagers
are since they're so
um uh self-centered you know just and
I'm not saying that like to [__] on them
that's just what they think their whole
world is that's just the way teenagers
are so you know them being that
self-centered you know you would think
that the whole world was looking at you
anyway even before social media existed
so I can imagine now that the
potentially the whole entire world could
be looking at you your [__] could go
viral yeah that's what I mean so it's
like you never know like look at that
see I always think about this this poor
thing that I saw this a long time ago
but there was this picture I don't know
if it went viral or not but I ended up
seeing it so it must have been somewhat
viral because I don't usually see any of
this kind of crap because I'm because I
don't really look at it all that much
but there was this one I can't remember
if it's a photo or video of this girl
and I guess she'd been at like some frat
party or whatever and she got super
super hammered which you know just
happened to the best of us right and she
passed out on the lawn and [__] herself
okay so
um they take pictures and then they took
of course everybody No One's Gonna help
her everyone's just gonna stand around
taking pictures and like laughing and
then it's gonna be all over the [__]
internet and now suddenly the whole
entire world knows you as that girl that
[__] herself yeah you know what I mean
like I don't think you could really see
her face but I'm sure like her immediate
friend group knew who it was and I'm
sure they [__] shared that with
everybody so it's like so that's the
thing so we were kind of lucky because
when we did stupid [__] like I never had
that it was hard to have a camera back
in those days yeah it was like I never
had anything as bad as that happened
thankfully but
um you know it if it did you wouldn't
have like 40 people taking pictures of
that and like uploading it to social
media for everybody to look at and like
you know what I mean so that was so that
was nice to statistics and everything
that I've been getting recently in the
[__] uh they're talking about the
dating market and stuff evidently our
generation in high school was having a
lot more sex than they had to than
they're having now evidently they're not
very sexual because like I said it could
go very wrong you got social media they
tell on each other taking pictures that
might be why well because they're
terrified of each other yeah
that's it's very very easily because
look like you could hook up with
somebody and it could be like [__]
awesome and then like a week or two
later you know you might decide that you
hate each other and then that person
like it decides they're gonna take
revenge on you and splash your [__] all
over and they've recorded all kind of
[__] recorded revenge porn there's a
whole there's a word for that revenge
porn and they're gonna we didn't have
that that really wasn't fun I mean I had
that happen to a friend of mine
yeah but not in high school not in high
school no just like a few years ago we
didn't have the technology right but
yeah so I get it I mean I get it because
it's like you have to navigate
um these really volatile situations and
there's a lot more consequences nowadays
than there would have been back then you
know what I mean like back then if you
you know maybe [__] somebody you
shouldn't have and like you know your
school might find out about it and you
might be a pariah there but it's like
you know it wouldn't spread beyond that
probably but nowadays it totally could
especially if it was something really
egregious or crazy or something I'm not
sure if [__] the wrong person was
ever a thing because there was a lot of
people in our high school that probably
[__] the wrong person we didn't know
you know I mean like who is the wrong
person it's just opinion I don't think
we really cared about that it was just
if
the only girl I can think think of is
that
and Crafters is on here he knows exactly
who I was talking about okay we went to
high school again
it's a real popular girl she was [__]
pretty as [__] she was one of the
cheerleaders
she had sex with uh one of the athletes
I think it was one of the football
players in in the in the uh the library
and uh after that got out and then he
goes on tells everybody of course he did
he tells everybody
and uh I mean dudes have been doing that
like since time immemorial like it's
just Amplified now because of social
media but dudes were always doing that
yeah and actually even if they didn't
[__] you they would tell other people
that they [__] you even if they didn't
I'd heard that that had happened and I
wouldn't believe it was I didn't at the
time didn't believe it was true I heard
some people say no no that evidently
happened
and I thought the girl the girl was
gorgeous
over a period of a couple months that
girl became goth
really started to think yeah it did
happen
yeah because she was just kind of trying
to like disappear into the walls or
something I think what happened was she
decided to change her identity no I
think what happened was is that she lost
all those she lost all those uh
uh [__] Jack and Jack friends and all
those cheerleader friends and she
started going Counter Culture
for her that's what she did she probably
ended up a lot happier yeah she started
going out with like one of the punk rock
guys
so it worked out good he was cool so I
remember correctly it was Bill
Grand Theft Bill uh
wingerton I think is what his name was
or pitbull
I don't know Crafters probably remember
that's the thing it's it's funny because
it was a tall good looking punk rock guy
I always kind of feel like and The
Breakfast Club does this a little bit
too where Ali sheedy's character is kind
of seen as they you know they call her
the basket case and she's a little bit
crazy but that's totally the type of
chick I would have hung out with in high
school not gonna lie
um I wasn't that weird in high school
but
I I was kind of that weird you know what
I mean yeah um but yeah so uh I do kind
of feel like it's saying that oh people
that look all gothy like that they just
need to be kind of like fixed or or they
dress like that because there's
something to matter with them yeah
they're and but that was a very 80s it
wasn't just The Breakfast Club a lot of
movies did that like in the 1980s like
if you looked gothy or you looked weird
or something like that there was some
reason like there was something the
matter with you that had to be like
corrected the girl I'm talking about his
name was Lisa
I think she just realized that those
people were [__]
[__] dude [__] you know the dude
they were just [__] she wanted
nothing to do with them they wanted
nothing to do with her but thing is is
that
[__]
her friends were doing worse [__] than
her
isn't that always the way I kind of feel
like that happens a lot it just depends
like I said and that's what I meant
about [__] the wrong person yeah so
the hypocrisy the hypocrisy got to her
and she said [__] this
and she started [__] dressing real
cool and [__] I don't blame her one that
was towards the end that was towards the
end of my last year at Trenton High I
went back to Brazil so I didn't see what
happened to her after that
yeah it might have been just a phase I
don't think it was that's what they were
hanging out with those people anymore
that's what they always say because I
would I mean I started dressing like
this in the 80s and I heard that just to
face [__] all the time I'm like well
it's you know 40 years later yeah did
she realized that those people really
weren't trustworthy you know they were
their real status oriented and and I
think it was Bill that she ended up with
and build I don't remember exactly bill
would have known the way he was he was
oh yeah that happened yeah [__] that
dude people are [__] [__] come
hang out with us man those people are
[__] yeah we're a lot nicer yeah
well I mean and I know you know you were
just doing what you do everybody else
does that that kind of [__] would be
exactly yeah to be honest with you
um I and I'm not speaking for everyone's
eyes because I know everyone's high
school was different but where I went to
high school it seemed like most of the
time like who you would call like The
Jock cheerleader princess preppy types
like you know like Andy and Claire in
The Breakfast Club they were doing way
more [__] yeah than any of the weirdos
yeah they were just getting away with it
they were just getting yeah they were
just getting away with it because they
were like oh you know they had wealthy
parents or they were on the football
team or whatever so they would like let
I mean they were like [__] alcoholics
they were doing like all kind of drugs
that like the women like the girls a lot
of them were total hoes and so well the
dudes were total hoes but it's like and
the thing about it was that you know I
knew you know a lot of the kind of like
goth Punk like alternative kind of
people some of them like did some drugs
too but it wasn't anything I mean most
of them were like just really nice
people yeah it's just regular like they
just weren't dicks where I feel like a
lot of the athletes and cheerleaders and
stuff like that were just like yeah
[__] man they were all kind of not all
of them like some of them were nice but
a lot of them here's the thing you know
what I mean I knew better the rumor was
that she had sex with a dude in the in
in the library I didn't believe it I
didn't believe it I knew exactly what
they were talking about I knew the girl
I was like nah
there's probably more like they were
making out maybe she [__] gave to do
the hand job or something like that
because I was thinking there's not
really people and I was like thinking
I'm like well
even if that happened this is [__]
because we're down going we're at the
drive-in [__] and [__] with each
other right in the cars right next to
each other I'd be in the back seat
[__] some chick with my buddy and hit
[__] his girlfriend in the front seat
[__] you know what I mean like what's
what's the problem
look at the drive and look at the line
of cars and half them cars are bouncing
up and down and everything and you go
yeah there's there's Jason and Tracy in
that car you know that car flying up and
down just you know you knew it was going
on it didn't matter I cut yeah I kind of
feel like everybody was doing that and
it's just kind of like so the fact that
they would pick out particular just all
the like [__] on about it yeah yeah
that's pretty [__] up and she was like
one of the pretty girls
who was one of the cheerleaders
and I don't know why they picked on her
she was one of the best looking ones and
probably the other girls did it
maybe or that dude might have made up
some [__] or he might have made it up
he might have lied that's what I'm
saying like you had to watch that too
because like some dudes would totally do
this it sounded fishy to me
yeah I mean I always like that I'd hear
[__] rumors go through the floor and
I was like nah that probably didn't
happen because I'd always [__] get
down to the bottom of it eventually like
it was something kind of like that but
not really
something happened that inspired that
tale you know it's like that yeah I'm
sure it's never quite the exaggerated
you're right yeah well the thing about
it I think they forget because there was
like a whole sub-genre of moving the
movies in the 80s I kind of feel like
breakfast club was the first one not
maybe not the first one but like the
first kind of mainstream teen movie that
actually was like a serious team of like
it had it's funny but it was serious
like taking
teenagers seriously like taking their
concerns seriously and I feel like that
hadn't really been done I felt like the
producers wanted it to be more like a
raunchy teen comedy like they had done
previously and you know that's another
reason why they didn't really want John
Hughes to do it and why they only gave a
million dollars but it ended up being
like a huge hit I think it ended up
making like 50 times its budget back so
you know what I mean and it's still
remember nowadays but I do kind of feel
like I've kind of think too there's a
whole sub-genre of movies in the 80s
that's all about virginity because it's
like it was such a huge deal in the 80s
and there's like a lot of it in this
movie too where they're trying to get
Claire to admit that she's a virgin and
then like you know Ali sheedy's
character she you know she says she's an
nymphomaniac and she's [__] all these
dudes but then like later on she says
she's a virgin too and she just made it
all up
um and all this other stuff and then
like Brian's character talking about he
didn't want Claire to know that he was a
virgin and all this other kind of stuff
so virginity was like a huge [__]
thing it was like a football in the 80s
like well and we're supposed to be a
verse I actually kind of like what Ali
Sheedy says in this because it's
absolutely true
she said
um that if you like if you say that you
are a virgin then you're a prude but if
you say you're not then you're a [__]
and I was like and I kind of feel like
that happened that was kind of the thing
in the 80s like especially for girls
um I feel like it was unacceptable for a
dude to be a virgin if he wasn't a
virgin then you know that was fine but
girls it was kind of
um you were kind of [__] either way I
might have to say it depending on what's
what crowd you were hanging out right
like in granters he's not I don't think
he's in the comment section you know we
when we were going when we were going to
Trenton high together we were we were
the drama program all kinds of [__] went
down and we didn't the drama kids didn't
play that we didn't care we consider
ourselves art artists all right yeah you
could do whatever you wanted you were
free
you know well see that's why I had gay
ones that were yeah
you kind of look sideways we had gay
ones you hear that yeah
we'd look a little bit we got gay ones
and everything we look sideways at him
you know maybe let go yeah you know what
I mean but it wasn't like uh you're not
a man [__]
we weren't mean to him or anything it's
not like they weren't our friends
you know we were working with them see
that was another reason why I gravitated
toward kind of the weirdo crowd yeah
like the gods and the punks and
everything like that because they were
just very even back in the 80s yeah they
were very chill about yeah what I've
yeah it's just like you know none of
them none of my business they're gonna
go out and bugger each other which like
I like Snickers but it's not like you're
kicking anybody's ass or anything like
that you stand up for them not leave him
alone you know that kind of [__] he's
all right you know it's just [__] like
that yeah so and and that was supposed
to be like a homophobic era according to
well
mainstream culture yeah was yeah
actually
um like I said that's kind of why I
didn't really hang out with like the
normies and stuff like that because they
were very
very I mean I had usually when a dude
worried about it too much I had a friend
so you're gay dude I had a friend in
high school who was not gay yeah but who
was
um he was possibly bi but he was kind of
um he was very gothy he had like the big
Robert Smith hair and eyeliner and
everything like that and he got his ass
kicked by jocks several times that's
ridiculous yeah um because
they thought he was gay yeah um so it
did happen a lot
I guess I don't know where you were
where I grew yeah I mean I grew up in
Daytona Beach they probably still do
that nowadays
um because there's still kind of stuff
they weren't doing that in Michigan they
weren't doing that in Brazil but but see
that's the thing like I said it you know
the Goss scene uh going back that far
even to the 80s was very it was a little
bit different but it was much more
hey it's like it's none of my business
everything that these people think that
they invented now now we had that [__]
back then we even had non-binary it's
called Duran Duran
that was easy
but you looked at him when you looked at
him though you you know what I mean it
was that was that was considered the
non-binary look for the 80s yeah and
that [__] was cool as [__]
it was like the height it was it was
very funny because like particularly the
80s early 80s New Wave yeah uh there was
a lot of you know what they called back
then gender bending although I guess
like David Bowie and [__] like that yeah
and the New York Dolls like did that
kind of stuff like back in the 70s but
went on for a long time but yeah but in
the 80s I kind of feel like it just
exploded it was like a huge thing and it
got like really popular even even Motley
Crue early Motley Crew you know the
[__] you could probably you'd
probably call that gender non-binary
today they're very they look very much
like the New York Dolls yeah they were
wearing their girlfriend's clothes their
girlfriends
so yeah so I kind of feel like that's
probably where it because they got their
look from Glam Rock and Glam Rock was
very uh was very gender neutral I guess
or it was kind of yeah very much into
that well what it was if you asked me
you got to be practical you know when
they're early on in their career these
Rock guys don't have a whole lot of
money they have girlfriends though
and in those days there just wasn't any
decent clothes for guys you couldn't get
anything that looked interesting it was
just [__] [__] flannel and
[__] Surfer clothes and [__]
girls had all the [__] best clothes
and they were cheap they were cheaper
and they could fit on a guy because they
were spandex a lot of the [__] back then
so they would just get one whatever they
just oh you know they were getting high
and [__]
in the studio with their girlfriends and
they're knocking their girlfriends down
like hold on hold on he puts on her
clothes because this looks pretty good
I'm gonna [__] let me sing like this
they're in there singing like that
that's probably how that [__] started
yeah it looked like [__] uh something
out of the New York Dolls yeah David
Johansson how much of those boots you
got Babe man if I had a pair that could
fit me that would look good in this you
know what I mean you got those then she
shows up with a size 10 size 11 or
something you know yeah yeah yeah yeah
because the selection for guys was back
then sucked it was pretty dire sucked
yeah yeah but the women's selection was
a lot better they had a lot more to
choose from so I think some of that [__]
was happening then Rock was just from
necessity that you just couldn't get you
guys close
see that's what I always kind of like
because that's the thing I dudes in a
lot of ways
um are a lot more restricted there's
only like a a certain
you know parameters of like what they
can that's like quote unquote acceptable
for them to look like
um so I feel like women have a lot more
leeway yeah what they could wear in that
regard like what they can wear and stuff
so I'm glad that that's kind of like
expanding outward nowadays but now you
got good men's selections now yeah yeah
yeah now you can get all kinds of you
know now you can get whatever you want
get all kinds of boots and all kinds of
shoes and [__] you know what I mean you
could tell it looks like something for a
man you know like yeah it's mad stuff
but this is new it's got buckles and
this and that on it oh wow that so this
selection today especially online
shopping man that was a dream come true
back in the 80s I'd give it a testicle
to have [__] online shopping camera
notice back I don't have testicles but
if I did yeah I totally would have hell
yeah I'll give it you would have ruled
the scene with the clothes that you
could get today yeah if you could go
back in time yeah holy [__] everybody
who think you were like King goth man
yeah
where'd you get that [__] rockstars had
that [__] and it was all custom made
yeah you couldn't buy it yeah and uh but
now you can buy that [__]
buy it online you don't have to go
anywhere to buy to get it
and that was just a fantasy back in
there you know what though I was gonna
say I just I just thought of this
um even nowadays
with all with all of the technology at
our fingertips people are still
impressed because we were in Publix
yesterday yeah and I had two I had two
women I was there I saw it come up to me
like the first woman she was like a
younger woman and she came up to me and
she said everything about you is
fabulous fabulous yeah she says and I
wasn't like super super dressed up or
anything like that I just had like a
short dress on in my boots and stuff
like that yeah and um and she's like you
were like the goth princess that I know
I am inside but I can't be because I
don't have the Wardrobe and I was just
like okay and then like later on I was
like you know buying some tuna or
something like that and this older lady
comes up to me and she's like
your boots where did you get those she
was like freaking out about it she
wanted a new workout and I didn't
remember where I got those where did I
go did we get them online somewhere yeah
I figured I was like I just got him off
a funky pair okay you remembered you're
devonia I think you were down at the
other end of the aisle yeah I couldn't
ask you you're one of the demonia brands
that was uh I love those kind of a rock
flat comfy boots yeah they were kind of
a new rock knock inspired design a bunch
of metal and to me it's like I didn't
really look and there's like Tom said
this coming out he's like you don't even
look that you know it's like you just
look like you regularly look yeah like
I'm not like super dressed up like to go
to the club or anything like that so
it's like fun look at what she's wearing
now [__] I love this [__] top I told
you this is the one I just got yeah see
it's Dario Argento it's stand up a
little bit so they can see it okay hold
on hold on wait a minute it's a half
shirt yeah it's like a it's like a crop
hoodie yeah but I got it from uh
killstar
yeah let's see it's awesome
yeah cool right got chains on it and
everything yeah actually Sophie
sent me the link to kill star and she's
like look at this Jenny oh my God I
thought of you they have a whole Dario
Argento collection
and I wanted pretty much everything in
there they had some [__]
um uh what do you call them uh what do
you call the pan the bell bottom pants
that are like the um the pattern from
the floor in Suspiria like the red and
black like diamond like oh and they're
so cool but it's just like I couldn't
afford everything in there obviously so
I just picked this because this was like
my favorite thing but man they had like
some really really cool [__] Zach's
going on about being androgynous that we
used to call it androgynous yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
he says um yeah whatever did happen to
something just being androgynous there's
a lot of words I even remember people
using for stuff that we just don't know
yeah which might fit more to be honest
yeah and he says same with how when
someone acts weird they're automatically
on the Spectrum yeah what if they're not
eccentric is a word that could still
work yeah right yeah yeah that's true
yeah you don't really hear people using
the word androgynous anymore
not as much but yeah that was something
that that was a term that was thrown
around a lot in the 80s mostly against
Annie Lennox I feel like she was getting
called androgynous all the time although
she looked [__] fantastic
to me she looked feminine I love that
cropped red hair and that suit like the
in the um Sweet Dreams video she looked
[__] great they just didn't want to
they just didn't wanna they were just
trying to label her
yeah well that's what they always do
they want to like she was a beautiful
woman in a suit with short hair
beautiful woman with a beautiful voice
yeah and with short buzz cut kind of
hair it was right it totally worked it
looked good it looked real good I love
that yeah it made a huge impression like
when I saw that I'm like oh my gosh the
norm he's freaked out but that look was
around in the [__] fetish scene for a
long time yeah shaving women bald was
like a fetish and then well I mean the
normies are always kind of slow pick up
on shade it's like yeah we saw that like
right
they've been doing that around here for
a long time it's just that nobody really
like saw it like in that wide of a
context before I guess
um Jeffy art points out too yeah I've
forgotten to mention this but in
mainstream culture being gay became
conflated with AIDS thereby adding the
stigma yeah I remember that being a big
[__] thing yeah because I don't think
it was as much of an issue in the 70s
pre-ades
hey I think I think
I think the fear what you would call
homophobia probably accelerated with
AIDS epidemic oh big time and it was
never really an epidemic it's most it's
basically stayed within gay people well
and intravenous drug users yeah it never
really went mainstream but they kept
scaring the [__] out of us telling us
that it was going to take over the
entire planet that once it got into
straight people that it would [__]
fly it would it would spread over the
whole world and everyone would have it
you know so it's kind of like this
apocalyptic
fear-mongering we're trying to make
money yeah it sells papers yep you know
what I mean uh Daniel Rowling said
didn't Catholic schools in the 80s have
the students sign abstinence waivers to
God or some [__] like that uh yeah
actually I think some of them still do
that nowadays yeah so that has not gone
away from the 80s I think Liberty
University still does that yeah and it's
probably all [__] and they're not
allowed to uh date interracially either
it's right there Liberty University
Liberty what is that that's owned by
isn't that owned by um one of those
[__] televangelists Pat Robertson or
is it Pat Robertson or something like
that yeah it even says like right there
in the bylaws I don't know if they might
have taken it out but if they took it
out it was only a couple years ago but
yeah you weren't allowed to like uh date
someone of another race or anything what
is that
because they're uh really [__]
backwards how is that religious oh I'm
sure they'll find some justifications
for it because they always do there was
nothing in that they always do yeah so I
know that the Mormons the LDS did that
for a little while yeah but then they
they backed off of that yeah because we
did didn't we we were talking about that
too like because didn't we do a show on
Mormons or we were talking about the
Mormons or something like that and yeah
up until very recently
um the Mormons were very kind of like oh
you know it's kind of like the whiter
you are the closer to God
pretty much yeah
that's a little problematic a little
problematic yeah
um well it wasn't problem back to the
people who wrote it
who wrote all that stuff that's the way
they thought they thought that was just
natural
yeah it's just that's the way the 1800s
were it was what mid-1800s they didn't
know [__] they just that was their
opinions
yeah I mean and I kind of feel like they
also 100 200 years from now we won't
know [__] but that's good that's that's
just the natural order they also
probably thought that Jesus was blonde
here in blue eyed and was a real guy who
actually lived I think some people
nowadays still think that yeah right so
you know what I mean because that's
what's up that's what that's what's on
the side of the church right yeah well
you know they want him to look like
[__] white ass Jesus yeah white ass
Jesus uh I grew up as a Christian I
believed it I'm still kind of a consider
myself to be a I'm a mythicist
I would kind of call myself a cultural
Christian I have it in my influence
thing is a
I'm a Jesus mythicist uh Jesus is a
mythological character that dude never
lived uh [__] it took me a while to
reach that but I just listened to the
right guys who [__] actually said
what the New Testament actually says and
what it doesn't say and where all this
come from and why it's why why it is a
Roman religion it has nothing to do with
the Middle East
uh yeah that guy couldn't have lived and
if he did live nothing of him remains
everything in the in the New Testament
is church doctrine that was put in there
much much later
so there's no
if there was a Jesus
who was recorded in a Bible nothing of
him remains so therefore the Jesus that
you believe in
isn't the one that actually was around
if he was around but chances are there
was no Jesus
you know which is kind of mind-blowing
to a person who
kind of grew up with taken for granted
that at least yeah that guy existed it's
just they made a religion around him nah
I guess it was like Dionysus I guess it
wasn't really that big a deal to me
because like I said I wasn't raised
religious so it wasn't like it was some
big like you know World shattering like
[__] information I was just kind of
like oh yeah I guess that well I didn't
really believe most most of what the
religion said but I thought there was a
Jesus I thought they made a religion
around this guy who's a preacher and it
and over time it grew into a religion no
no
it's made up out of whole cloth it's a
copy of a Roman religion it's basically
Dionysus
among others I mean there's a whole
borrowing from every [__] thing
there's tons and tons of other myths
that are basically just like that that
are being kind of like cobbled together
yeah it's really interesting I think
it's really interesting like looking
back at all it's a Roman copy of a
Jewish religion
and the Romans did that a lot they had
Persian copies of a Persian religion
called mithras Cult of mithras yeah look
that [__] up that's it we should do a
show about that yeah yeah we should do
that there's not much to survives about
mithras but the cult of Christianity and
Cult of mithras in ancient Rome existed
side by side for a long time they're
and it eventually Cult of Jesus
swallowed up mithras
all your real big churches are built on
ruins of mithraic temples and stuff
and there's a lot of stuff in the Jesus
story that seems to be bald from mithras
about the last supper and how many
disciples there were and all that 12.
same as the sign of the zodiac well
wasn't that that was kind of from Norse
mythology too was it not which one
mistress the whole no the whole um Last
Supper thing because then that then that
happened and like with uh in Norse
mythology I think there's last suppers
evidently were a religious tradition
amongst a bunch of religions they've
just borrowed everything
it's like we like the part of this story
it's like going through the salad bar
and just like picking out whatever like
a buffet the flood stories yeah you know
a lot of religions have flood stories
yeah and they're yeah we talked about
that before like how they're very
similar one of the oldest well the
oldest one that was written down as far
as I know was from epic of a gilgament
yeah Gilgamesh they're talking about
Gilgamesh yeah probably because
everybody believed that that happened
everybody believed that that was a
historical event and it was a cool book
so both religions start with that flood
uh Ben asked is Dario Argento know about
this about this shirt
um I imagine he had to have signed off
on it because they have a whole
collection and it has what I assume are
copyrighted images well obviously
because this is the poster the original
poster from Opera they have like a dress
with that has the Suspiria poster on it
they have like all that kind of stuff so
I'm assuming that he gave permission
um Jeffy art said oh yeah I remember
this too said well AIDS did go into the
population via unprotected sex yep
especially in low-income communities yep
that did happen it wasn't until Magic
Johnson publicly disclosed his HIV
status that the stigma somewhat lifted
yeah I remember that because he was
super super famous at the time and the
fact that he had the balls to come out
and say that he had it
um that was like a huge but it never it
never went pandemic though no no the
transmission between heterosexual
couples isn't isn't solid enough
it's not easily Tran it's not as easily
transmitted it's more easily transmitted
to women by males than to males from by
women the transmission
female to male isn't as good
it's not as likely
it just it just it just couldn't go
pandemic it's not that kind of but I
remember that it was just this whole oh
my God it was like such a big deal like
in the 80s you can get it now and live a
normal life evidently have a normal
lifespan yeah you just like have
antiviral medicines yeah they got
medication and steroids alone [__] man
you even see I've even seen like
commercials on TV yeah like for um for
the medications they give it to you so
you can just like live a normal lifespan
not like it I mean in the 80s if you got
it it was like a death sound yeah
essentially and like a lot of people
what they tried to do what they tried to
cure him with they knew that was a
[__] and all the Anthony fauci and
those guys were involved with that AZT
and he knew that evidently they knew
that that was a real loser but they had
uh Financial investment in AZT
and uh another dude said another dude
just says well it looks like a wasting
disease they just started pumping them
full of [__] steroids and that kept
them alive a lot longer than [__] like
AZT
then you start throwing well-known
antiviral medicines in there that helps
even more but now they got real good
antivirals they can keep it wrapped up
for 50 60 70 years well [__] that's a
lifespan
30 or 40 and they can keep you alive for
70 years that's a long time and keep you
from passing it to other people yeah
right well yeah you count so low you
can't pass that yeah that's what I'm
saying yeah keeps your count sound down
yeah slasher friend said one of the
Classic Movies to disclose uh to be
about AIDS was Philadelphia yeah that
was uh with Tom Hanks I remember seeing
that I think I might have seen that in
the theater that's a great [__] movie
but you look how bad um Freddie Mercury
looked yeah they could have just pumped
him full of [__] natural oil which is
a steroid and it would have probably
bought him 20 years
and all they had to do is give them but
put him on steroids but they didn't know
they didn't know they didn't know I mean
that's the thing
they didn't really know until I kind of
feel like fairly recently yeah
they kind of figured that [__] out had
they had him on that it's kind of they
just should have just followed their
[__] their their nose looked at their
eyes he's wasting away well what is the
common
given thing for [__] wasting disease
steroids
they [__] brought them right back
keep them alive help them fight it and
then he would have been around long
enough for better antiviral medicines to
come around
but uh the thing is is you can't patent
them so the big big Pharma is involved
they're like well we can't patent that
we're not gonna make much money we got
to come up with something else I don't
trust them I just don't [__] trust
them never did business Ben says poor
Liberace was a human skeleton he put out
stories in the press that he was on a
radical watermelon only diet yeah
because you couldn't really admit it
right
you know what I mean I think even
Freddie Mercury didn't really admit it
until like right before he died yeah but
that was that was just a No-No you just
didn't do it back then in the 80s
because then everybody would like
[__] freak out
so it's kind of a shame and I'm glad
that we've gotten away from that because
I do kind of remember what that was like
but Tammy Faye Baker helped with [__]
bringing it out of the closet we talked
about that earlier remember that yeah
when we said yeah she said we shouldn't
be getting around you know we shouldn't
be turning uh turning these uh AIDS
people away you know
which that was the cool thing about
Tammy fig yeah she was actually not a
terrible person like we talked about
that when we talked about our
televangelist show I said of all these
[__] chuckle [__] that we talked
about on that show she seemed like the
only one that was like a halfway decent
person yeah I'm not saying she wasn't a
grifter because she was oh but um out of
all of them she was like really the only
decent person like somewhat decent but
um I was gonna say something else and I
forgot what it was but uh yeah we've
we've thrifted very very far away from
breakfast Club Didn't we how did that
yeah yeah that's a talk show
all right I'm gonna get something to eat
too so oh yeah okay
so Danny Rowling asked earlier what our
haunting episode tomorrow is going to be
because tomorrow's haunting Mondays yeah
uh we're gonna do nightmare upstairs
which is season five episode six now we
did
um last week we did season five episode
four uh but so I was gonna do five but
that was dark dreams and we already did
that one okay right so the next one is
Nightmare upstairs so that's what we're
gonna do I have I don't even remember
this one at all but we gotta like watch
this one tonight not gonna take notes on
it and that's what we're gonna do
so uh so yeah so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this discussion of The Breakfast
Club and other things as we do go into
talking about other [__] although we
talked about breakfast club most of the
time yeah to be fair to us yeah okay so
uh so yeah so hopefully you guys can
come by tomorrow evening at 7 30 p.m
Eastern Standard Time for haunting
Mondays uh like I said we're gonna be
talking about nightmare upstairs so
we'll see you guys again tomorrow thanks
for dropping by today and we'll see you
tomorrow night